nous sommes le PDG protégeant de réveiller d'or, nous
prions et serons protégés
tout au long de la nuit si votre père ne le fait
pas entrer rapidement,
vous êtes un visiteur des plus indésirables et nous
ne proposons pas de vous divertir, vous les
trouverez facilement moins vous avez gagné  Je ne suis pas ici
assez longtemps pour que tu te retrouves ici pour la première fois Es
-tu toujours intéressé par moi par ta
force J'essaie juste de leur donner
ce dont ils ont besoin pour survivre en ces temps
si tu pouvais avoir quelque chose dans le monde
ce qui serait  c'est
que j'ai été emmené loin de moi tu as l'
air d'être un
recenseur  prends le sel maintenant
apporte-moi le livre d'anatomie
si je t'apporte quelque chose donne-moi la
clé tu sais que je peux ramper en le
versant pour être fidèle
toi
[Musique]